Oil sands operations contribute significant carbon emissions in Canada. So the six largest companies have teamed up to make strides on the path to NetZero. Investing in technology and innovation. Already cut emissions in average 22% per barrel. Working with governments to create and protect jobs. Developing one of the world's largest carbon capture and storage facilities. Our NetZero plan is in motion and we're making progress on multiple pathways. See our plan in action at pathwaysalliance.ca
加拿大油砂运营产生了显著的碳排放。因此，六家最大的公司携手合作，在通往净零排放的道路上大步迈进。他们投资于技术和创新，已将每桶石油的平均排放量降低了22%。他们与政府合作以创造和保护就业岗位，并正在开发世界最大之一的碳捕获与储存设施。我们的净零排放计划正在实施中，我们正通过多种途径取得进展。请访问 pathwaysalliance.ca 亲眼见证我们的计划付诸实践。
Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. It was a crisp spring night on May 13, 1974 when a young woman walked out of a Salzburg bar with a smartly dressed stranger. Julia, not her real name, had started chatting to the man after he initiated a conversation with her. Although they had just met, Julia was more than impressed with his charming and talkative manner. As he led Julia outside, he offered her a lift home, gesturing to his expensive Ford Mustang parked across the street. Accepting his offer, Julia hopped into the car's passenger seat.
我们的节目涉及严重且往往令人痛心的事件。如果您在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系您当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，请查看您手机应用上或我们网站上的本集节目简介。那是1974年5月13日的一个清爽的春夜，一个年轻女子和一个衣着考究的陌生人走出了萨尔茨堡的一家酒吧。朱莉（化名）在那个男人主动与她搭话后开始与他聊天。尽管他们刚见面，朱莉对他的迷人谈吐留下了极其深刻的印象。当他带着朱莉走到外面时，他指着停在街对面的一辆昂贵的福特野马轿车，提出开车送她回家。朱莉接受了他的邀请，跳上了汽车的副驾驶座。
As the Mustang drove away from the bright lights of Salzburg and into the surrounding countryside, Julia realised that the man was driving in the opposite direction of her home. She began to panic. They headed down a small laneway and into a meadow surrounded by dense bushes. It was completely deserted. With no street lights to illuminate the area, all was pitch black outside. Julia's fear grew. Then, just as the man drove deeper into the field, the car became stuck in the mud.
当野马车驶离萨尔茨堡明亮的灯光、驶入周边的乡村时，朱莉意识到这个男人正朝着她家的反方向开去。她开始惊慌失措。他们驶入一条小巷，来到了一片被茂密灌木丛环绕的草地。这里四下无人，荒凉无比。由于没有路灯照明，外面漆黑一片。朱莉的恐惧与日俱增。就在这个男人将车开向田野更深处时，车子突然陷进了泥地里。
Suddenly, they stopped. As the Mustang's wheels turned and turned without gaining any traction, Julia saw her chance. She leapt from the passenger seat and began sprinting across the field. But the man followed. He was quick, catching up in no time and tackling her to the ground. He shoved her face in the mud to silence her screams, then began beating the back of her head. After he roughly removed her shoes, he tore off her stockings and used them to bind her hands behind her back. Dragging Julia back to the car, the man sexually assaulted her with a steel pole while he masturbated.
突然，他们停了下来。野马的车轮空转着却无法获得任何抓地力，朱莉看到了机会。她从副驾驶座上跳下来，开始在田野里狂奔。但那个男人追了上来。他速度极快，转眼间就追上了她并把她扑倒在地。他把她的脸按在泥地里以压制她的尖叫声，然后开始殴打她的后脑勺。在他粗暴地脱掉她的鞋子后，他扯下她的长袜，用它们把她的双手反绑在背后。男人把朱莉拖回车里，用一根钢管对她进行了性侵，同时自己在一旁手淫。
When he was finished, he freed Julia from her restraint. Headlights suddenly illuminated the field behind them. Another car had pulled up to the scene. Its occupants had noticed the Mustang stuck in the mud and the driver walked over to assist. Julia's attacker got out and greeted him, feigning distress over his car's state. As they spoke, Julia saw her second chance to escape. She clambered out of the Mustang and raced over to the other car, frantically asking the passenger to take her to the police. He agreed and called over the driver so they could leave immediately.
完事后，他解开了束缚朱莉的绳索。身后的田野里突然亮起了车灯。另一辆车开到了现场。车上的人注意到那辆野马陷在泥里，司机便走过来帮忙。朱莉的袭击者下了车并迎了上去，假装为自己车子的状况感到苦恼。在他们交谈时，朱莉看到了第二次逃跑的机会。她爬出野马车，冲向另一辆车，语无伦次地请求乘客带她去警察局。对方同意了，并把司机叫了过来，以便他们能立即离开。
As they pulled away, carrying Julia to safety, their car's headlights cast a bright light over her attacker in the meadow. He stared back, still standing next to the Ford Mustang, stuck deep in the mud. 7 months after the attack on Julia, 18-year-old Margaret Schaffer said goodbye to her friends after spending the evening bowling with them and began to walk home. Margaret lived in Eversbach, Germany, approximately 650km north of the Austrian city of Salzburg. As she strolled along the footpath, a Mercedes pulled up alongside her. Glancing inside, Margaret saw her friend Barbara sitting in the passenger seat. Barbara asked Margaret if she would like a lift home to save walking in the cold night air.
当他们开车离去、将朱莉带往安全地带时，他们车的车灯将强光投射在草地上的袭击者身上。他回望着他们，依然站在那辆深陷泥潭的福特野马旁边。在袭击朱莉7个月后，18岁的玛格丽特·沙弗在和朋友们一起保龄球度过了一个傍晚后向大家道别，开始步行回家。玛格丽特住在德国埃弗斯巴赫，距离奥地利城市萨尔茨堡以北约650公里。当她沿着人行道漫步时，一辆梅赛德斯轿车停在她身旁。玛格丽特往车里一瞥，看到她的朋友芭芭拉正坐在副驾驶座上。芭芭拉问玛格丽特是否需要搭车回家，以免在寒冷的夜风中步行。
Margaret gratefully agreed. 3 weeks later, a group of hunters were navigating through a dense copse of trees in a wooded area outside of the German town of Haerborn. As they carefully made their way through the forest, they spotted something. Lying face down beneath a tall conifer was the naked body of a woman. Someone had tried to cover her with leaves and branches, but her skin and dark curly hair were still visible. It was Margaret Schaffer. Her wrists had been restrained before she was beaten about the head with a blunt object. Then her attacker had used Margaret's own bra to strangle her.
玛格丽特感激地答应了。3周后，一群猎人在德国哈尔博恩镇外的一片树林里穿行于茂密的灌木丛中。当他们小心翼翼地穿过森林时，他们发现了一些东西。在一棵高大的针叶树下，面朝下躺着一具女性裸尸。有人试图用树叶和树枝掩盖她，但她的皮肤和黑色的卷发依然清晰可见。她就是玛格丽特·沙弗。她的手腕在被钝器击打头部之前曾遭到捆绑。接着，袭击者用玛格丽特自己的胸罩勒死了她。
It had been expertly tied in a unique series of knots to form an extremely taut ligature. German detectives attended the location and commenced an investigation, making sure to interview those close to Margaret. This led them to her friend, Barbara. It wasn't long before she cracked under the pressure. 24-year-old Jack Unterweger was already well known to authorities in the neighbouring country of Austria. In 1970, Jack abducted a 16-year-old girl and tried to force her into sex work. His extensive rap sheet also featured charges for robbery, car theft, burglary and fraud. Over time, Jack added sexual assault to his long list of criminal convictions.
它被专业地打成了一系列独特的结，形成了一条极其紧绷的勒带。德国侦探赶到现场并展开调查，务必对接近玛格丽特的人进行盘问。这使他们找到了她的朋友芭芭拉。没过多久，她在压力下崩溃了。24岁的杰克·温特韦格对邻国奥地利的当局来说已经是个老熟人了。1970年，杰克绑架了一名16岁女孩并试图强迫她从事性工作。他那厚厚的犯罪记录中还包括抢劫、偷车、入室盗窃和诈骗等多项罪名。随着时间的推移，杰克将性侵犯也加入了其长长的定罪名单中。
Women were easy targets for him. He presented himself as intelligent, gregarious, wealthy and well-groomed and was able to charm his victims. Despite his urbane persona, the truth was that Jack was broke and could not read or write. Throughout 1973 and 74, Jack's assaults landed him short stints in prison, but every time he was released, he attacked again. Over time, his violence against women escalated, like the time he attacked Julia in a field outside Salzburg. Having gotten a good look at Jack, she quickly identified him as her attacker and he was sent to prison for the assault in mid-1974. After attempting to take his own life, Jack was transferred to a local psychiatric hospital. A few months later, he was released and decided to make a fresh start in Frankfurt, Germany.
女性对他而言是轻而易举的目标。他把自己包装成聪明、合群、富有且衣着光鲜的形象，并能够迷住受害者。尽管有着温文尔雅的人设，但事实是杰克身无分文且不识字。在1973和74年间，杰克的袭击行为让他多次短暂入狱，但每次刑满释放后，他都会再次作案。随着时间的推移，他对女性的暴力行为不断升级，就像当年他在萨尔茨堡郊外的草地上袭击朱莉那样。由于记清了杰克的长相，朱莉很快认出他就是袭击自己的人，他因此于1974年中期因袭击罪被判入狱。在企图自杀未遂后，杰克被转送到当地的一家精神病院。几个月后他获释，并决定在德国法兰克福重新开始。
It was there that he began dating a young woman named Barbara. On the night of December 11, 1974, Jack and Barbara decided they needed some easy cash and hatched a plan to rob Barbara's parents. They drove from Frankfurt to Barbara's hometown of Eversbach and headed directly to her family's house. They'd expected to find it empty, but to their dismay, Barbara's parents were home. Their plan foiled, the couple began driving around town looking for someone else to rob. Soon, they spotted Margaret Schaffer walking all alone. Barbara knew Margaret well, she had previously lived next door to her and the two were friends. Barbara told Jack as much and he hastily pulled over so they could offer Margaret a lift.
正是在那里，他开始和一个名叫芭芭拉的年轻女子交往。1974年12月11日晚，杰克和芭芭拉决定搞点快钱，于是策划了一场抢劫芭芭拉父母的计划。他们从法兰克福开车来到芭芭拉的家乡埃弗斯巴赫，直奔她家。他们本以为房子会是空的，然而令他们沮丧的是，芭芭拉的父母在家。计划泡汤后，这对情侣开始在镇上到处闲逛，寻找其他人作为抢劫目标。很快，他们发现玛格丽特·沙弗正孤身一人步行。芭芭拉对玛格丽特很熟悉，她以前曾和她做过邻居，两人是朋友。芭芭拉将此告诉了杰克，杰克便急忙把车停下，以便他们能搭载玛格丽特。
She happily accepted. The two women chatted in the car's back seat while Jack drove. After a little while, he stopped by the side of the road. As recounted in the book Entering Hades by John Lake, Jack asked Barbara, Do you have anything else you want to tell her? When Barbara said no, Jack remarked, then now we'll get to the point. He grabbed Margaret by her shirt, finding her slim frame easy to pull into the front seat. Using Barbara's belt, he restrained Margaret's hands behind her back.
她高高兴兴地接受了。杰克开车时，两个女人坐在汽车后座上闲聊。过了一会儿，他把车停在路边。正如约翰·莱克在《进入冥界》一书中所述，杰克问芭芭拉：“你还有什么别的想对她说的吗？”当芭芭拉回答没有时，杰克说：“那我们现在就切入正题。”他抓住玛格丽特的衬衫，轻而易举地将她那瘦削的身躯拉到了前排座位上。他用芭芭拉的皮带将玛格丽特的双手反绑在背后。
After rifling through her belongings and pocketing some cash, Jack drove to Margaret's house. Barbara let herself inside with a key from Margaret's purse. She wandered through the residence, pocketing about $40 from Margaret's room and grabbing some clothing as well. Meanwhile, Jack waited in the car with Margaret. He had pushed her to the rear footwell and she was unable to move. When Barbara returned, Jack drove 30km south to Haerborn, asking Barbara if she knew of any woodlands nearby. As Margaret sobbed in the back of the car, Barbara directed Jack past the restaurant and onto a forest road. Jack drove deep into the woods, then parked the car.
在翻遍她的随身物品并搜走一些现金后，杰克开车把车开到了玛格丽特家。芭芭拉用从玛格丽特钱包里拿到的钥匙潜入了屋内。她在住宅里四处搜寻，从玛格丽特的房间里顺走了大约40美元，还拿了一些衣物。与此同时，杰克和玛格丽特留在车里。他把她推到后排的地坑里，使她动弹不得。芭芭拉回来后，杰克向南驱车30公里来到哈尔博恩，问芭芭拉附近有没有什么树林。当玛格丽特在车后座啜泣时，芭芭拉指引着杰克驶过餐馆，开上了一条林间小路。杰克将车开进树林深处，然后停下了车。
He untied Margaret and ordered her to take her clothes off, but she refused. Jack punched her in the face before undressing her himself. When he hopped out of the car, Margaret asked Barbara what he was going to do to her. Barbara just shrugged in reply. Jack reappeared and grabbed a steel rod from the glove box, then dragged Margaret from the car. He asked Barbara if she'd like to accompany him. She declined, but watched as Jack dragged a naked Margaret across the snow-covered ground. They disappeared into a thicket of nearby trees.
他松开玛格丽特，命令她脱掉衣服，但遭到拒绝。杰克狠狠地打了她一记耳光，然后自己动手剥光了她的衣服。当他跳下车时，玛格丽特问芭芭拉他究竟想对自己做什么。芭芭拉只是耸了耸肩膀作为回应。杰克重新出现，从杂物箱里拿出一根钢棒，然后将玛格丽特从车里拖了出来。他问芭芭拉是否愿意陪他一起去。芭芭拉拒绝了，但她看着杰克拖着赤身裸体的玛格丽特走过白雪覆盖的地面。两人消失在附近的一片灌木丛中。
In a statement, Barbara later told detectives, I was terribly afraid for her, but also for myself. About 15 minutes later he came back to the car, and after he sat in the driver's seat, he handed me the steel rod, which was covered with blood and hair. What did you do with her? I asked him. He replied, There's no way she can betray us now. While there was no physical evidence from the crime scene linking Jack to the murder, his girlfriend Barbara's confession was enough to warrant action. On January 17, 1975, just a month after Margaret's murder, Jack Unterweger was arrested and charged.
在一份陈述中，芭芭拉后来告诉侦探：“我当时为她感到极度害怕，也为我自己感到害怕。”大约15分钟后，他回到了车里；坐上驾驶座后，他把那根沾满血迹和头发的钢棒递给了我。“你把她怎么了？”我问他。他回答道：“她现在绝对不可能再背叛我们了。”尽管犯罪现场没有将杰克与这起谋杀直接联系起来的物证，但他女友芭芭拉的供词已经足以采取法律行动。1975年1月17日，就在玛格丽特遇害一个月后，杰克·温特韦格被捕并被起诉。
Due to a treaty between Germany and Austria, Jack, an Austrian citizen, would be tried in his homeland, despite killing Margaret in Germany. It is unclear whether his girlfriend Barbara faced any legal ramifications for her actions on the night of Margaret's murder. In July 1975, while still waiting for Margaret Schaffer's murder trial to begin, Jack Unterweger was tried for violent offences against four other women in Austria. He was found guilty and sentenced to three years in prison. One year into his sentence, the murder trial finally commenced. In court, Jack wore a dark suit with a gaudy tie, while his long shaggy hair fell around his face. Short, slim and baby-faced with delicate features and small, wide eyes, Jack Unterweger didn't look like a stereotypical criminal. The prosecution instructed those present to look beyond his appearance as they heard the evidence against him.
由于德国和奥地利之间的一项条约，身为奥地利公民的杰克尽管是在德国杀害了玛格丽特，却将在他的祖国接受审判。目前尚不清楚他的女友芭芭拉是否因其在玛格丽特遇害当晚的行为而面临任何法律后果。1975年7月，在等待玛格丽特·沙弗谋杀案开庭审判期间，杰克·温特韦格因在奥地利对另外四名女性实施暴力犯罪而受审。他被判有罪，并被判处三年监禁。服刑一年后，谋杀案审判终于开庭。在法庭上，杰克穿着深色西装，系着一条花哨的领带，蓬乱的长发垂在脸颊两侧。杰克·温特韦格身材矮小、苗条、有着娃娃脸、精致的五官以及细小而睁得圆圆的眼睛，看起来并不像个传统的罪犯。检方指示在场人员透过他的外表去看待针对他的证据。
The trial drew a large crowd. They listened attentively as Jack's defense team spoke of his troubled childhood. He was born in 1950 in the historic Austrian town of Udenborg. His mother was a waitress and sex worker. Jack's father, who he never met, was an American soldier. He'd been part of a group of US troops occupying the area following the end of World War II. When Jack was about 18 months old, his mother was jailed for fraud and he was sent to live with his grandfather in a desolate, run-down cottage in the Austrian countryside. It was during this time that Jack struggled the most.
庭审吸引了大量旁听者。他们聚精会神地听着杰克的辩护团队讲述他坎坷的童年。他于1950年出生在奥地利历史名镇乌登堡。他的母亲是一名女服务员和性工作者。杰克的父亲是一个美国士兵，他从未见过对方。其父曾是二战结束后参与占领该地区的美国部队成员之一。杰克大约18个月大时，他的母亲因诈骗罪入狱，他被送到奥地利乡下一个荒凉破旧的小屋里跟祖父生活。正是在这段时间里，杰克经历了最大的挣扎。
His grandfather was a violent alcoholic who beat Jack for misbehaving. Jack often claimed that he was forced to sleep in the same bed as his grandfather while the elderly man had sex with various girlfriends and sex workers. However, this was likely not true, with many of Jack's stories about his childhood being embellished and exaggerated for sympathy. Ever since his arrest, Jack Unterweger had denied murdering Margaret Schaffer. But on the stand, he suddenly broke down. He admitted to beating Margaret and then strangling her with her own bra. When he'd looked into her face, he saw his mother's, which caused him to explode with rage and hatred. Jack sobbed and pleaded for forgiveness.
他的祖父是一个暴力的酒鬼，经常因为杰克不听话而殴打他。杰克经常声称，当这位老汉与不同的女友和性工作者发生性关系时，自己被迫和祖父睡在同一张床上。然而，这很可能并非事实，杰克关于童年的许多故事都是为了博取同情而添油加醋、夸大其词的。自被捕以来，杰克·温特韦格一直否认谋杀玛格丽特·沙弗。但在证人席上，他突然情绪崩溃。他承认自己殴打了玛格丽特，然后用她自己的胸罩勒死了她。当他看着她的脸时，他看到了他母亲的脸，这导致他内心的愤怒和仇恨瞬间爆发。杰克痛哭流涕，恳求原谅。
Instead of being forgiven, he was found guilty and given a life sentence to be served at Stein Prison, a maximum security facility in Cremes, Austria. Police Inspector August Schenner sat in the courtroom listening to Jack Unterweger's sentencing with interest. The murder of Margaret Schaffer bore strong similarities to a case that had landed on his desk three years earlier. On April 1, 1973, the body of a petite woman with long black hair was found floating in a lake in Salzburg. Aged in her mid-twenties, she wore a turtleneck jumper and was naked from the waist down. The woman's ankles had been tied together tightly with her stockings and her wrists bound expertly behind her back with a necktie. A bandage, likely taken from a car's first aid kit, was wrapped multiple times around her head and mouth, acting as a makeshift gag. She had been violently beaten across the face, but the cause of her death was drowning.
非但没有得到原谅，他被判处有罪并被判处无期徒刑，将在奥地利克雷姆斯的最高安全级别监狱施泰因监狱服刑。警务督察奥古斯特·申纳坐在法庭里，饶有兴致地听着对杰克·温特韦格的宣判。玛格丽特·沙弗的谋杀案与他三年前处理过的一起案件有着高度的相似之处。1973年4月1日，一具身材娇小、留着黑色长发的女性尸体被发现漂浮在萨尔茨堡的一个湖泊中。她二十多岁年纪，身穿高领套头衫，腰部以下赤裸。这名女性的脚踝被她的长袜紧紧捆绑在一起，手腕则被一条领带专业地反绑在背后。一条很可能是从汽车急救包里拿出来的绷带在她头部和嘴巴周围缠绕了好几圈，充当临时口塞。她的面部曾遭到猛烈殴打，但其真正的死因是溺水。
An autopsy revealed the woman had sexual intercourse just prior to her murder, but it could not be determined if she had been raped or if it was consensual. When tire marks were discovered leading to the lake's shoreline from the surrounding woodland, a horrifying picture began to emerge. The woman had been undressed, restrained and gagged, then dragged from a car to the lake and thrown in while still alive. The following morning, a man named Mato Horvath reported his wife missing. Marika Horvath had failed to return home after catching a bus into Salzburg two nights prior. Mato was taken to see the body of the woman recovered from the lake and was devastated to find that she was his wife, Marika. At the time, Austria had one of the lowest violent crime rates in the world and murders were virtually unheard of. Catching Marika's killer was of the utmost importance, so the country's top detectives were assigned to the case and no expenses were spared.
尸检显示，这名女子在遇害前不久曾发生过性行为，但无法确定她是遭到强奸还是自愿行为。当人们发现轮胎印从周围的树林一直延伸到湖岸边时，一幅令人毛骨悚然的画面逐渐浮现。这名女性先是被脱光衣服、捆绑并塞住嘴巴，然后从车里拖到湖边，在活着的时候被扔了进去。第二天早上，一个名叫马托·霍瓦特的人报案称他的妻子失踪了。马托的妻子玛丽卡·霍瓦特在乘公交车前往萨尔茨堡两天两夜后一直未归。马托被带去查看从湖中打捞上来的女性尸体，痛苦地发现死者正是他的妻子玛丽卡。当时，奥地利是世界上暴力犯罪率最低的国家之一，谋杀案几乎闻所未闻。抓住玛丽卡的杀手至关重要，因此该国顶尖的侦探被指派负责此案，并不惜一切代价。
Despite this, a lack of leads and physical evidence had authorities coming up empty. Over time, the investigation dwindled and the murder gradually faded from public attention. But it remained firmly in the mind of investigating officer August Schenner. Although he couldn't find the man responsible, August was certain of one thing. Whoever killed Marika was a sadistic monster. When he later learned about the murder of Margaret Schaffer in Germany, August was struck by the similarities her case brought to that of Marika Horvath. He sat in on Jack Unterweger's trial, taking in every detail. The more he heard, the more certain he was that Jack was the man he'd been looking for.
尽管如此，由于缺乏线索和物证，当局一无所获。随着时间的推移，调查陷入停滞，这起谋杀案也渐渐淡出公众的视线。但它依然牢牢印在调查警官奥古斯特·申纳的脑海中。尽管他找不到真凶，但奥古斯特坚信一件事：杀害玛丽卡的凶手是一个虐待狂魔。当他后来得知德国发生玛格丽特·沙弗谋杀案时，奥古斯特被该案与玛丽卡·霍瓦特案的惊人相似之处深深震撼了。他旁听了杰克·温特韦格的庭审，吸收了每一个细节。他听得越多，就越确信杰克正是他一直在寻找的那个人。
But he didn't have enough evidence to charge him. As Jack's sentence was read aloud to the court, August Schenner took comfort in the fact that at least Jack was now facing life behind bars. On June 19, 1991, 15 years after Jack Unterweger went to prison, 20-year-old Shannon Exley stood on the corner of Seventh and Main in downtown Los Angeles. Behind her, the sign for the Cecil Hotel was brightly illuminated in the night sky. Shannon had been working in the sex industry since she had run away from home at the age of 16. She used her earnings to support her drug habit, but earlier that night she'd called her father, telling him she was going to get her life back on track and was looking forward to a brighter future.
但他没有足够的证据来起诉他。随着杰克的刑期在法庭上被大声宣读，奥古斯特·申纳感到一丝宽慰，因为至少杰克现在面临着牢狱之灾。1991年6月19日，在杰克·温特韦格入狱15年后，20岁的香农·埃克斯利站在洛杉矶市中心第七街和主街的转角处。在她身后，塞西尔酒店的招牌在夜空中熠熠生辉。香农自16岁离家出走以来一直从事性工作。她用挣来的钱维持毒品瘾，但在当晚早些时候，她给父亲打了个电话，告诉他自己要重回正轨，并对光明的未来充满期待。
Just after midnight, a car pulled up alongside her. Shannon Hopped In The next morning, a group of girls were picking up trash behind the parking lot of the girls' scout center, two and a half miles from where Shannon had been standing the night before. As they worked, the girls noticed something lying in a vacant, overgrown lot approximately 50 feet beyond the car park. They drew closer to get a better look. It was the body of a murdered woman. Shannon Exley was lying on her stomach underneath a tall eucalyptus tree.
刚过午夜，一辆汽车停在她身旁。香农跳上了车。第二天早上，一群女孩正在距离香农前一晚站立地方两英里半的一个女童子军中心停车场后面捡垃圾。在工作时，女孩们注意到在停车场外大约50英尺远的一个荒芜杂草丛生的空地上躺着什么东西。她们走近以便看个究竟。那是具被谋杀的女性尸体。香农·埃克斯利面朝下躺在一棵高大的桉树下。
She was naked, except for a t-shirt that had written up around her shoulders and a pair of bright blue socks. Around her neck was her bra, tied tight in a series of unique and complex knots. Whoever had attacked Shannon had used her bra to strangle her. Cuts and scrapes on her feet indicated she'd been dragged through the vacant lot, then dumped. Seaman from a number of different men was extracted from Shannon's body. None matched DNA profiles of anyone on record. The murder had been carried out in a clean, meticulous fashion, and there was no evidence left at the scene. Detectives concluded that the killer must have planned the slaying, scoping out the area in daylight, as it was not a sight clearly visible at night.
她赤身裸体，只穿着一件卷到肩膀上的T恤和一双亮蓝色袜子。她的脖子上缠着她的胸罩，打成了一串独特而复杂的死结。袭击香农的人是用她的胸罩勒死了她。她脚上的割伤和擦伤表明她曾被拖过那片空地，然后被抛弃。从香农体内提取出了几名不同男子的精液。没有一个人的DNA与档案中的任何人相匹配。这起谋杀案手法干净利落、一丝不苟，现场没有留下任何证据。侦探们得出结论，凶手一定精心策划了这起谋杀，并在白天对该地区进行了踩点，因为这里在夜间并不清晰可见。
It was a puzzling location. Detectives knew that the city's sex workers rarely travelled more than a block or two from where they were picked up. The distance from Shannon's last known location suggested she had not gone to the lot willingly. Ten days later, a homeless man was looking for firewood one and a half miles from where Shannon Exley was found. As he searched around the parking lot of a freight company, he noticed something beneath a big rigged trailer. It was the body of a woman, lying on her back and naked, aside from a t-shirt and one sock. She had been hit in the abdomen so forcefully that it caused internal damage, but the cause of her death was ligature strangulation. The woman's own bra was knotted tightly around her neck.
这是一个令人费解的地点。侦探们知道，该市的性工作者很少会走到距离她们上车地点一两个街区以外的地方。从香农最后已知地点的距离来看，她并非自愿前往那片空地的。十天后，一名无家可归的男子在距离发现香农·埃克斯利一英里半的地方寻找柴火。当他在一家货运公司的停车场周围搜寻时，他注意到一辆大型拖挂卡车下方有什么东西。那是具女性尸体，仰面朝躺着，赤身裸体，只穿着一件T恤和一只袜子。她的腹部遭受了猛烈撞击，导致内脏受损，但她的真正死因是勒颈窒息。死者自己的胸罩被紧紧地打结缠绕在脖子上。
Her name was Irene Rodriguez, and she was 33 years old. Irene had been in Los Angeles for less than three months, performing sex work to support a heroin addiction. She left behind a husband and four children. Irene had worked on the same corner as Shannon, just down the road from the Cecil Hotel. Just as in Shannon's murder, her killer left no evidence and a forensic examination resulted in zero leads. Detectives suspected Irene's attacker may have been a trucker from out of town, given where her body had been dumped. Sex workers who frequented the area where Shannon and Irene were taken were worried. Many were friends, and words spread quickly amongst their community that two women had been killed while working.
她的名字叫艾琳·罗德里格斯，年仅33岁。艾琳来到洛杉矶不到三个月，靠从事性工作来维持海洛因瘾。她身后留下了一个丈夫和四个孩子。艾琳和香农在同一个街角工作，距离塞西尔酒店只有几步之遥。正如香农的谋杀案一样，她的凶手没有留下任何证据，法医鉴定结果也完全没有提供任何线索。考虑到抛尸地点，侦探们怀疑艾琳的袭击者可能是个外地卡车司机。在香农和艾琳被带走的地区出没的性工作者们感到忧心忡忡。许多人都是朋友，两名女性在工作时遇害的消息在她们的社群中迅速传开。
Some shared their fears with a journalist who was writing a series of articles on the dangers of sex work in Los Angeles. Known for his compassionate understanding of controversial topics, he wrote an article about the murdered women for Tiroline magazine, an excerpt of which read, Real life in LA is dominated by a tough struggle for survival, by the broken dreams of thousands who come to the city and an equal number who leave, sometimes dead. Sex workers who knew Shannon Exley and Irene Rodriguez opened up to the sympathetic journalist, describing how the murders had impacted them and crying over the loss of their friends. In one recorded interview, an unnamed woman said, It's ugly. It's dirty. It's scary. Every time you walk out on the street, you take your life in your hands. You could die every time you get in a car. Every time you drive away, you don't know this person. You don't know if he's going to kill you.
一些人将她们的恐惧分享给了一位记者，该记者当时正在撰写一系列关于洛杉矶性工作危险性的文章。他以对具争议话题富有同情心的理解而闻名，他为《蒂罗林》杂志撰写了一篇关于被谋杀女性的文章，其中摘录写道：“洛杉矶的现实生活由残酷的生存斗争、数千名来到这座城市却梦想破灭的人主宰，还有同样数量离开的人，有时他们是死着离开的。”认识香农·埃克斯利和艾琳·罗德里格斯的性工作者们向这位富有同情心的记者倾心吐露，描述了谋杀案对她们的影响，并为失去朋友而痛哭流涕。在一次录音采访中，一名未具名的女性说道：“这很丑陋。这很肮脏。这很吓人。每次你走到街上，你都是在拿自己的生命冒险。每次你上车都可能会死。每次你开车离开，你根本不认识这个人。你根本不知道他会不会杀了你。”
Two weeks after the murder of Irene Rodriguez, a deputy sheriff drove to a deserted Malibu hilltop in response to a frantic call received by the LA County Sheriff's Department. As described in John Leigh's book, Entering Hades, the deputy was met at the scene by a group of men and their children. They'd headed there to view a solar eclipse that was set to black out the Los Angeles skyline by mid-morning. Instead, they had stumbled across the body of a dead woman. She was lying on her back with her shirt up around her shoulders, exposing her breasts. Otherwise, she was fully clothed. Her fingerprints identified her as Peggy Booth, a sex worker who worked on Hollywood's Sunset Boulevard, approximately seven miles from where Shannon and Irene were picked up. Detectives assumed Peggy must have known her murderer well, as the desolate location where she was found was not a place she would usually frequent. Just like Shannon and Irene, Peggy had been strangled to death with her own bra.
在艾琳·罗德里格斯遇害两周后，一名副警长驱车前往马里布的一个荒凉山顶，以回应洛杉矶县治安官部门接到的一个紧急求助电话。正如约翰·雷伊的书《进入冥界》中所述，这名副警长在现场遇到了几名男子和他们的孩子。他们去那里是为了观看预定在上午中期遮蔽洛杉矶天际线的日食。相反，他们无意中发现了一具女尸。她仰面躺着，衬衫卷到肩膀上，露出了胸部。除此之外，她衣着完整。通过指纹鉴定，死者是佩吉·布思，一名在好莱坞日落大道工作的性工作者，距离香农和艾琳被接走的地方大约七英里。侦探们推测佩吉一定很了解她的凶手，因为发现她尸体的荒凉地点并不是她通常会去的地方。就像香农和艾琳一样，佩吉也是被她自己的胸罩勒死的。
While the murder of sex workers in Los Angeles was tragically not a rare occurrence, this identical manner of killing was. Dr Lynn Herald from the LA County Sheriff's Department analyzed the ligatures. In the hundreds of strangulation murders Dr Herald had seen over the course of her career, these three were the only ones she had come across where a victim had been strangled by their own undergarments. The fact that the victim's bras had all been dismantled and tied together in the exact same way left her in no doubt that the same person was responsible for all three murders. Detectives began surveilling downtown Haunts where sex workers were known to operate in case the killer struck again. But he never did. On July 16, 1991, the journalist who had reported on the slayings in Los Angeles boarded a flight back to his home country. He'd gathered ample material for his work comparing the differences between sex work in LA and Europe, and intended to broadcast these findings in a radio series for the Austrian Broadcasting Corporation.
虽然在洛杉矶谋杀性工作者悲剧性地并非罕见，但这种完全相同的作案手法却十分罕见。洛杉矶县治安官部门的琳恩·赫拉德博士对这些勒带进行了分析。在赫拉德博士在其职业生涯中见过的数百起勒死谋杀案中，这三起是她仅见的受害者被自己的内衣勒死的案件。受害者的胸罩都被拆卸并以完全相同的方式系在一起，这让她毫不怀疑这三起谋杀案都是同一个人所为。侦探们开始监视性工作者出没的市中心常去地点，以防凶手再次作案。但他再也没有出现。1991年7月16日，这位曾报道洛杉矶谋杀案的记者登上了飞回祖国的航班。他已经为自己比较洛杉矶和欧洲性工作差异的作品收集了充足的素材，并打算在奥地利广播公司的广播系列节目中播报这些发现。
He also planned to write several articles on the same topic. It was a busy time for the journalist, in addition to his investigative deep dive, he also had a book to promote with public signings. In his homeland, the journalist was a beloved public figure with thousands of fans who adored his empathetic writing style. He considered himself a ladies' man and picked up women effortlessly, even having a whirlwind romance with one of the Cecil Hotel's receptionists. She hoped to visit him in Austria soon. The journalist was Jack Unterweger. Jack Unterweger's prison sentence for the murder of Margaret Schaffer, who he had abducted and strangled to death in 1974, coincided with the period of reform in Austria's penal system. The nation's Minister for Justice implemented a program based on the theory that even the most violent criminals could be successfully rehabilitated whilst incarcerated.
他还计划就同一主题撰写几篇文章。对这位记者来说，这是一段繁忙的时期，除了深入调查之外，他还有一本书要通过公开签名售书来进行宣传。在祖国，这位记者是一个备受爱戴的公众人物，拥有成千上万崇拜他那富有同情心的写作风格的粉丝。他自认为是情圣，毫不费力地就能搭讪女性，甚至与塞西尔酒店的一名前台接待员展开了一场旋风般的浪漫恋情。她希望不久后能去奥地利看望他。这位记者就是杰克·温特韦格。杰克·温特韦格因谋杀玛格丽特·沙弗（他于1974年将其绑架并勒死）而判处的刑期，恰逢奥地利行刑制度改革时期。该国司法部长实施了一项基于以下理论的计划：即使是最暴力的罪犯，在服刑期间也能被成功改造。
One prisoner who took advantage of the new opportunities offered was Jack Unterweger. He became a regular at the prison library, teaching himself to read and write. Over time, he discovered that he had a natural talent for the written word. He began writing plays, poetry and short stories for children. While he remained behind bars, his short stories were broadcast over the radio, to the delight of many parents and children who tuned in. In 1983, eight years into his sentence, Jack Unterweger completed his autobiography and titled it Fiegerfeuer, which translates to purgatory in English. Jack told of his tragic childhood and the despair of prison life, neglecting to mention why he was imprisoned. The book was published later that year and became a bestseller.
利用新提供的机遇的囚犯之一就是杰克·温特韦格。他成了监狱图书馆的常客，自学读写。随着时间的推移，他发现自己在文字方面有着天生的才能。他开始为儿童写戏剧、诗歌和短篇小说。虽然身陷囹圄，但他的短篇小说通过广播播出，令收听节目的许多父母和孩子欣喜不已。1983年，即他入狱八年后，杰克·温特韦格完成了他的自传，并将其命名为《Fiegerfeuer》，在英文中意为“炼狱”。杰克讲述了他悲惨的童年和监狱生活的绝望，却闭口不谈自己为何入狱。这本书于当年晚些时候出版，并成为畅销书。
People felt connected to Jack and his compassionate descriptions of life behind bars. He seemed relatable, genuine and sensitive. But police inspector Auguste Schenner hadn't forgotten about Marika Hovart, the woman who drowned in Salzburg Lake. He remained convinced that Jack Unterweger was responsible and arranged to interview him in prison. A girlfriend of Jack's had written a statement placing them in Salzburg on the night of Marika's murder. She recalled that Jack had left without explanation for a period of the night and also remembered Jack keeping newspaper clippings about the murder. When she pressed him for information about the clippings, he threw them away. When Auguste Schenner confronted Jack with this information in prison, he burst into tears and told the investigator that if this line of questioning continued, he would return to his cell and hang himself.
人们感觉自己与杰克以及他对狱中生活的富有同情心的描述产生了一种联结。他显得平易近人、真诚且敏感。但警务督察奥古斯特·申纳并没有忘记玛丽卡·霍瓦特——那个在萨尔茨堡湖中溺水的女人。他仍然确信杰克·温特韦格是罪魁祸首，并安排在监狱里对其实施讯问。杰克的一个女友曾写下一份陈述，将他们置于玛丽卡遇害当晚的萨尔茨堡。她回忆说，杰克曾在当晚的一段时间里不辞而别，并且还记得杰克保留了关于这起谋杀案的剪报。当她追问这些剪报的信息时，他把它们扔掉了。当奥古斯特·申纳在监狱里拿着这些信息质问杰克时，他放声大哭，并告诉调查人员，如果这种盘问继续下去，他将回到牢房上吊自杀。
Undeterred, Inspector Schenner appealed to the district attorney to prosecute Jack for Marika's murder. As per Austrian law, Jack could only serve one life sentence, but if he was found guilty of killing Marika, time would be added to his current term. The district attorney declined to proceed with the case, telling Inspector Schenner, He already has a life sentence, he can only be given one. It was suggested that his decision was influenced by the strong links Jack had to prominent Austrians, who wholeheartedly enjoyed his body of work. Although Inspector Schenner was outraged, he had nowhere else to turn. It wasn't long before Figefeuer caught the attention of Austria's literary elite. They praised the autobiography, describing it as the ultimate example of the power the arts had to transform lives.
申纳督察毫不退缩，向地区检察官上诉，要求起诉杰克谋杀玛丽卡。根据奥地利法律，杰克只能服刑一次无期徒刑，但如果他被判谋杀玛丽卡罪名成立，刑期将被追加到他目前的刑期中。地区检察官拒绝继续审理此案，并对申纳督察说：“他已经身负无期徒刑，只能被判一次。”有人暗示，他的决定受到了杰克与极力欣赏其作品的奥地利名流之间深厚联系的影响。尽管申纳督察感到愤怒，但他已无路可走。没过多久，《Figefeuer》就引起了奥地利文学精英们的注意。他们对这本自传大加赞赏，称其为艺术改变生命力量的终极例证。
Those responsible for the country's prison reform held up Jack Unterweger as their greatest success story. In 1984, Jack received an award for his work, a stage production titled Terminal Prison. He was permitted day release to attend the opening night performance, and arrived to a throng of photographers clamouring to take his picture. In 1985, Austria's literary community began to petition for Jack's early release. His editor recalled a reading Jack gave in Stein Prison, stating, At his reading, he was so tender, and at that moment we decided we had to get him pardoned. But Austrian President Rudolf Kirschlager refused to sign off on Jack's release, pointing out that he was legally required to serve at least 15 years of his life sentence.
该国监狱改革的负责人们将杰克·温特韦格奉为他们最伟大的成功案例。1984年，杰克因其名为《终点监狱》的舞台剧作品而获奖。他被准许日间假释以出席首演之夜的演出，到达时受到了一群争相拍照的摄影师的簇拥。1985年，奥地利文学界开始请愿要求提前释放杰克。他的编辑回忆起杰克在施泰因监狱的一次朗读时说道：“在他的朗读中，他是如此温柔，就在那一刻，我们决定必须为他争取特赦。”但奥地利总统鲁道夫·基尔施拉格拒绝签署释放杰克的命令，指出按法律规定他必须至少服满无期徒刑中的15年。
In 1988, Jack's autobiography was adapted into a film. He collaborated with its director, but differences in artistic vision became evident when Jack continually requested to be portrayed as a hero. The director disagreed, unable to look past the Jack's conviction for murder. He believed Jack had a massive ego, and only used his writing as a means to escape prison, later telling British newspaper The Guardian. Jack doesn't like literature. Jack doesn't like writers. Jack doesn't like anything. Jack only likes Jack. Nevertheless, the film was released to positive reviews, and as the movie gained popularity and Jack's book was taught in Austrian high schools, support for his release only increased. On May 23, 1990, 39-year-old Jack Unterweger left prison as a free man, having served his minimum term of 15 years. His release was due in part to the campaigning of psychiatrist Dr Ernest Borneman, who never met Jack, but had read his autobiography.
1988年，杰克的自传被改编成电影。他与导演合作，但当杰克不断要求将自己塑造为英雄时，两人在艺术愿景上的分歧显现了出来。导演不同意，无法忽视杰克因谋杀而被定罪的事实。他认为杰克有着极度膨胀的自我，只是把写作当成逃离监狱的工具，后来他对英国《卫报》说：“杰克不喜欢文学。杰克不喜欢作家。杰克什么都不喜欢。杰克只喜欢杰克。”尽管如此，这部电影上映后获得了好评，随着电影越来越受欢迎、杰克的书被奥地利高中作为教材教授，要求释放他的呼声也随之高涨。1990年5月23日，39岁的杰克·温特韦格服满了15年的最低刑期，作为自由人走出了监狱。他的获释部分归功于精神病学家恩斯特·博恩曼博士的游说，博恩曼博士从未见过杰克，但读过他的自传。
Dr Borneman wrote a letter to the Justice Minister, which read in part, The man committed a serious act, is remorseful, understands the motive of his actions at the time, and has the means never to have a relapse. I am convinced that this act will never be committed again. Upon Jack's release, one prison warden said, We will never find a prisoner so well prepared for freedom. A psychologist at Stein Prison, who was straight out of university, had an hour-long conversation with Jack, and wrote that he was now fit for society, having worked on his problems with intellectual rigor. Jack Unterweger was welcomed back into the community with open arms. He settled into an apartment in Vienna, and bought a German shepherd he named Joy. When Jack walked down the street and dated cafes, he was constantly interrupted by people wanting to talk to him.
博恩曼博士写信给司法部长，信中部分内容写道：“此人犯下了严重的罪行，但已有悔意，理解当时行动的动机，并且具备永不复发的条件。我确信这一行为绝不会再次发生。”在杰克获释时，一名狱警说道：“我们再也找不到一个为自由做如此充分准备的囚犯了。”施泰因监狱的一位刚从大学毕业的心理学家与杰克进行了长达一小时的谈话，并写道他现在适合回归社会，因为他已经以严谨的学术态度解决了自己的问题。杰克·温特韦格受到社区的热烈欢迎。他在维也纳安顿下来，买了一只德国牧羊犬并取名叫“乔伊”。当杰克走在街上或约会咖啡馆时，总是会被想要和他交谈的人打断。
He soaked up this newfound celebrity status. Soon, Jack was given a job as a reporter with the Austrian Broadcasting Corporation. He went to photo shoots, sometimes posing shirtless to reveal the prison tattoos that covered his torso. On one occasion, he thought it would be amusing to take a series of photos posing with a noose around his neck. Jack attended book signings and gave public poetry readings. He became a regular on magazine covers and talk shows. A fortnight after being released from prison, he appeared on the popular national television program Club 2 and debated the topic of penal reform with other esteemed authors. The panellists described Jack as an exception to the prison rehabilitation program, which had since been deemed unsuccessful for 99% of inmates. In response, Jack said,
他沉浸在这一新获得的知名度中。很快，杰克在奥地利广播公司获得了一份记者的工作。他去参加拍照，有时光着膀子摆姿势，露出覆盖上半身的监狱纹身。有一次，他觉得摆出一系列脖子上套着绞索的姿势拍照会很有趣。杰克出席签售会并公开朗诵诗歌。他成了杂志封面和脱口秀节目的常客。出狱两周后，他出现在受欢迎的国家电视节目《俱乐部2》中，与其他受人尊敬的作家就刑罚改革话题进行辩论。小组成员将杰克描述为监狱改造计划的一个例外，该计划此后被认为对99%的囚犯宣告失败。对此，杰克说：
They fail, they end up in homeless shelters, because they don't have the inner strength to fend for themselves. It was less than four months after Jack went to Vegas release that the murders of vulnerable women began. Regina Prem was a sex worker in Vienna, Austria, who provided for herself and her husband Rudolph, as well as their young child. On the night of April 28, 1991, she had an appointment with a regular client, so Rudolph dropped her off at an intersection in Vienna's Red Light District. She said goodbye to him, then got out of the car. Rudolph waited at home for Regina's phone call, saying she was ready to be picked up. Hours ticked by. When 2am came and went with no call, Rudolph grew concerned.
“他们失败了，最终流落到无家可归者的收容所，因为他们没有自立的内在力量。”就在杰克获释不到四个月后，针对弱势女性的谋杀案开始了。雷吉娜·普雷姆是奥地利维也纳的一名性工作者，她靠自己养活自己、丈夫鲁道夫以及他们年幼的孩子。1991年4月28日晚上，她与一个老客户有预约，于是鲁道夫开车把她送到维也纳红灯区的一个十字路口。她向他道别，然后下了车。鲁道夫在家等待雷吉娜打来电话说她准备好被接回去了。时间一分一秒地过去。当凌晨2点到来却依然没有电话时，鲁道夫开始感到担忧。
He began driving around the city streets in search of his wife, but there was no sign of her. A food vendor came forward to say he'd spotted Regina at around 11.30pm, leaving a hotel she often frequented with wealthy clients. This was the last confirmed sighting of Regina Prem. A month passed with no leads. Rudolph Prem issued a public plea, telling reporters for the V&E's newspaper Courier, quote, I don't want to believe she's dead. Maybe she's been abducted and locked up somewhere. But if the lunatic has killed Regina, he should at least say where her body lies. My wife deserves a decent burial.
他开始开车在城市街道上寻找妻子，但毫无踪影。一名食品小贩站出来说，他在晚上11点30分左右看到雷吉娜离开了一家她经常与富有客户光顾的酒店。这是雷吉娜·普雷姆最后一次被确认目击。一个月过去了，没有任何线索。鲁道夫·普雷姆公开呼吁，对《V&E》报纸《信使报》的记者引述说道：“我不想相信她死了。也许她被绑架并关在某个地方了。但如果那个疯子杀了雷吉娜，他至少应该说出她的尸体在哪里。我的妻子配得上一个像样的葬礼。”
About five weeks later, Rudolph was at home when his phone rang. He answered it. A male voice on the other end said, At the Vienna Woods Lake, go left and follow the path that steeply ascends and forks. A few are lying there. The figure eight at the zenith stands, then I'll tell you where your wife lies. Rudolph abruptly hung up the call, believing he was a cruel hoaxer. He didn't report the incident to the police.
大约五周后，鲁道夫正在家里，电话铃响了。他接了电话。另一端传来一个男人的声音：“在维也纳森林湖，向左走，沿着陡峭上升并分叉的小径走。有些人在那里躺着。当数字8位于天顶时，然后我会告诉你你的妻子躺在哪里。”鲁道夫生硬地挂断了电话，认为这是一个残忍的恶作剧。他没有向警方报案。
At 11.45pm on October 8, 1991, Rudolph Prem received another call. The same voice from three months earlier stated, I am an executioner. On Toolbinger Hill lies Gerda. God commanded me to do it. Tonight I have completed my work. To 11. I have carried out the just punishment. Five hours later, the phone rang once more. Again, the anonymous man spoke. They lie in the place of atonement facing downward toward Hades
1991年10月8日晚上11点45分，鲁道夫·普雷姆又接到了一个电话。三个月前的那个声音说道：“我是个行刑者。在图尔宾格山上躺着格尔达。上帝命令我这么做的。今晚我完成了我的工作。11点。我已经执行了正义的惩罚。”五小时后，电话再次响起。匿名男子再次开口。他们在通往冥界的救赎之地上面朝下躺着
because otherwise it would have been an outrage. Rudolph continued to dismiss these calls. He had no idea that bodies had recently started turning up in the very area that the caller spoke of. The Vienna Woods are a 45km stretch of dense woodland that runs through Vienna and Lower Austria. The forest that expanse is a popular destination for those wishing to escape city life. Throughout winter, the bitter cold keeps all but the most determined of hike is away. But during the warmer months, when the snow melts and sun shines through the wooded canopy,
因为否则这就太令人发指了。鲁道夫继续对此类电话置之不理。他根本不知道，最近就在来电者所说的那片区域开始出现尸体。维也纳森林是一片长达45公里的茂密林地，纵贯维也纳和下奥地利州。这片广袤的森林是渴望逃离城市生活的人们的热门去处。整个冬天，刺骨的严寒把除了最坚定的徒步者之外的所有人都挡在了外面。但在较暖和的月份里，当积雪融化、阳光透过树冠洒落时，
the woods buzz with tourists and locals alike. On May 20, 1991, a 62-year-old man was walking along one of the woodland's paths when he noticed a putrid smell. Looking around for its source, he saw the body of a woman positioned on her stomach with her face pushed into the mud. She was naked aside from a leotard pushed up around her shoulders. One of her right leg was missing, chewed off by foxes. The body was that of 25-year-old sex worker Sabine Moitzel who had been reported missing five weeks earlier
森林里游客和当地人络绎不绝。1991年5月20日，一名62岁的男子正走在林间小路上，突然闻到一股恶臭。他四处寻找气味来源，发现了一具趴着的女尸，脸被按在泥土里。她赤身裸体，只有一件紧身衣被推到了肩膀周围。她的右腿少了一条，被狐狸啃掉了。死者是25岁的性工作者萨比娜·莫伊策尔（Sabine Moitzel），她于五周前被报失踪，
and was last seen on the street corner she frequented for work. Three days later, on May 23, a woman scouring the woods for her guinea pig's favourite food found another decomposing body, also lying naked and face down. It was 25-year-old Karen Eruglu-Slatke, a sex worker who'd worked a few blocks from Sabine Moitzel and had been reported missing two weeks earlier. Karen had been left deeper in the forest, suggesting her killer forced her to walk there naked. She had been violently beaten in the face and one of her ears was partially torn. Both women were killed in nearly exactly the same manner.
最后一次被人看到是在她平时揽客的街角。三天后的5月23日，一名在树林里为自己的豚鼠寻找最爱食物的女子发现了另一具正在腐烂的尸体，同样是赤身裸体、面朝下趴着。死者是25岁的卡伦·埃鲁格鲁-斯拉特克（Karen Eruglu-Slatke），她是一名性工作者，在离萨比娜·莫伊策尔几个街区的地方工作，两周前被报失踪。卡伦被丢弃在森林更深处，这表明凶手强迫她光着脚走到那里。她的面部遭到暴力殴打，其中一只耳朵部分被撕裂。两名女性遇害的手法几乎完全一致。
Sabine Moitzel was strangled with a stocking tied tightly around her neck in a complex series of knots. Karen Eruglu-Slatke was strangled to death with her leotard, tied in the exact same way. In November 1991, a month after Rudolph Prem received his third and final disturbing call, which included a reference to the Greek god of death, Hades, a couple strolling through the Vienna woods spotted a female body lying amongst a strand of trees. She was naked and positioned face down, crudely covered with branches and clumps of soil. Dental records identified her as Sylvia Zagla, a 23-year-old sex worker who was reported missing four months prior. She had been strangled to death with her own pantyhose.
萨比娜·莫伊策尔是被一双紧紧系在她脖子上的丝袜勒死的，上面打了复杂的一系列结。卡伦·埃鲁格鲁-斯拉特克则是用她的紧身衣勒死的，打结方式完全相同。1991年11月，在鲁道夫·普雷姆接到第三个也是最后一个令人不安的电话（其中提到了希腊死神哈迪斯）一个月后，一对在维也纳森林漫步的情侣在一丛树木中发现了一具女性尸体。她赤身裸体、面朝下，身上粗鲁地盖着树枝和成团的泥土。牙科记录确认死者是西尔维娅·扎格拉（Sylvia Zagla），一名23岁的性工作者，四个月前被报失踪。她是用自己的连裤袜勒死的。
The Vienna woods were concealing yet another victim. One year after Regina Prem went missing, a retired police officer and his wife went for a walk along the woods' highest hill located deep in the forest. As the officer passed a tree, he noticed a branch lying against its trunk and kicked it absentmindedly. As he did so, he noticed a piece of fabric tied around the branch. Then he realized something. He hadn't kicked a branch. It was a human femur bone concealed inside a stocking. The bone belonged to Regina Prem.
维也纳森林还藏着另一个受害者。雷吉娜·普雷姆（Regina Prem）失踪一年后，一名退休警官和他的妻子在森林深处最高的小山旁的树林里散步。当警官走过一棵树时，他注意到一根树枝靠在树干上，便心不在焉地踢了一脚。与此同时，他注意到树枝上缠着一块布。接着他意识到一件事。他踢的根本不是树枝。那是一根藏在丝袜里的女性股骨。这根骨头属于雷吉娜·普雷姆。
More of her skeleton was found scattered throughout the area, having been scavenged by wild animals. Around two weeks after the first bodies were found in the Vienna woods, a reporter from the Austrian Broadcasting Corporation strolled into police headquarters to speak with Chief Max Edelbacher. He explained that he had been assigned to cover the newly discovered serial killings because of his personal connection to the crimes, claiming that his aunt was a sex worker who had been murdered by a client decades earlier. Chief Edelbacher was happy to provide a statement saying, Despite a number of leads, so far we have obtained no positive result.
她的更多遗骸在周围地区被发现，散落各处，已被野生动物啃食。在维也纳森林发现第一批尸体大约两周后，奥地利广播公司的一名记者溜进警察局总部，与局长马克斯·埃德尔巴赫（Max Edelbacher）交谈。他解释说，由于自己与这些案件有私人渊源，他被指派报道新发现的系列谋杀案，并称他的姑姑曾是一名性工作者，几十年前被客户杀害。埃德尔巴赫局长很高兴地发表了一份声明，称：“尽管有许多线索，但到目前为止我们还没有取得积极的成果。”
What we are really missing is material evidence. The reporter sympathized with the situation, remarking, It must be very frustrating for an officer to, so to speak, run into such a dead end. After Chief Edelbacher's shift ended, he returned home and relayed the day's events to his wife. He told her about the journalist who had interviewed him, providing her with the man's name. His wife was surprised, but the chief didn't know why. He'd never heard of Jack Unterweger before. Jack was working on multiple pieces about the bodies found in the Vienna woods.
“我们真正缺少的是物证。”这名记者对这一局势表示同情，并评论道：“对于一个警官来说，可以说陷入这样的死胡同，一定非常令人沮丧。”埃德尔巴赫局长下班回家后，将当天的经过向妻子转述了。他向她讲述了采访他的那个记者，并告诉了她那个男人的名字。他的妻子很惊讶，但局长不知道为什么。他从未听说过杰克·翁特韦格（Jack Unterweger）。杰克当时正在撰写多篇关于维也纳森林发现的尸体的报道。
After Sabina and Karen were discovered, he interviewed sex workers from Vienna's Red Light District for an article. One woman voiced her fear that the killer had gotten away with it, stating, What can they do now? It's already too late to catch him. They should have taken the missing person's reports more seriously. A tone of dismay permeated Jack Unterweger's finished article. The dead in Vienna woods are another argument for why society should do more to provide security for prostitutes. The more securely integrated a prostitute is in society, the more she can work in safety, with less chance of falling victim to a crime. One individual following the coverage of the sex worker slayings with interest was former detective August Schenner.
在萨比娜和卡伦被发现后，他为了写一篇文章，采访了维也纳红灯区的性工作者。一名女性表达了她的恐惧，认为凶手已经逃脱法网，她说道：“他们现在能做什么？抓他已经太迟了。他们本该更严肃对待失踪人口的报告。”沮丧的基调弥漫在杰克·翁特韦格完成的文章中。“维也纳森林里的死者是社会应该采取更多措施为妓女提供安全保障的又一个论据。妓女越是安全地融入社会，她就能越安全地工作，沦为犯罪受害者的机率就越小。”前侦探奥古斯特·申纳（August Schenner）是密切关注这起性工作者谋杀案报道的人之一。
Although he'd long since retired from the police, Schenner had been fascinated by the news about the women found in the Vienna woods. They reminded him of a case that he'd never been able to set aside, the murder of Marika Horvat in Salzburg in 1973. When Jack Unterweger was charged with killing Margaret Schaffer sometime later, August Schenner became convinced he had murdered Marika as well. He'd never had enough evidence to charge him, but took some comfort in his suspect receiving a life sentence. Now, almost two decades later, Jack was a free man, and women were being killed again. August Schenner was certain he was responsible. He passed on a message to the police, which eventually reached Chief Max Edelbacher. Chief Edelbacher thought the tip sounded highly unlikely, but as he had no other credible suspect, he decided to put Jack Unterweger under surveillance, just in case.
尽管他从警察局退休已久，但申纳一直对维也纳森林发现女性的新闻着迷。这让他想起了一起他从未能放下的案件，即1973年在萨尔茨堡发生的玛丽卡·霍瓦特（Marika Horvat）谋杀案。后来，当杰克·翁特韦格被指控杀害玛格丽特·沙弗（Margaret Schaffer）时，奥古斯特·申纳确信他也谋杀了玛丽卡。他从未有足够的证据起诉他，但看到自己的嫌疑人被判无期徒刑，他感到有些安慰。现在，将近二十年过去了，杰克成了一个自由人，而女性再次被杀害。奥古斯特·申纳确信他是罪魁祸首。他向警方转达了一条消息，最终传到了局长马克斯·埃德尔巴赫那里。埃德尔巴赫局长认为这条线索听起来极不可能，但由于他没有其他可信的嫌疑人，他决定对杰克·翁特韦格实施监视，以防万一。
Jack led a somewhat lavish lifestyle. He often dined at cafes and restaurants with high-profile people. The rest of the time, he holed up in his high-end apartment and worked on his writing. The more Chief Edelbacher observed, the less he believed such a man could be his murderer. On June 10, 1991, Jack Unterweger paid another visit to Chief Edelbacher's office to tell him he was going to Los Angeles for five weeks to write about crime, the sex work industry, and law enforcement. He asked if the chief had any connections in the LAPD who could help him. Chief Edelbacher did not tell Jack that he was being looked at as a person of interest in the Vienna Woods crimes. Because he didn't consider Jack a likely suspect, he had no problem with him travelling to the USA. Jack Unterweger thoroughly enjoyed his time in Los Angeles.
杰克过着有些奢华的生活。他经常与名流在高档咖啡馆和餐厅用餐。其余时间，他则躲在自己高档的公寓里写作。埃德尔巴赫局长观察得越多，就越不相信这样一个人会是凶手。1991年6月10日，杰克·翁特韦格再次拜访了埃德尔巴赫局长的办公室，告诉他自己要去洛杉矶呆五周，以撰写关于犯罪、性工作产业和执法的文章。他询问局长在洛杉矶警察局是否有可以帮到他的关系。埃德尔巴赫局长并没有告诉杰克他已被视为维也纳森林案件的重点排查对象。由于他不认为杰克是重大嫌疑人，他对于杰克前往美国旅行没有任何异议。杰克·翁特韦格在洛杉矶度过了一段非常愉快的时光。
The morning after Shannon Exley was killed, he went sightseeing and unsuccessfully tried to track down various celebrities to interview, including Cher and Zha-Zha Gabor. He got amongst it at the Gay and Lesbian Pride Parade, and a few days after Irene Rodriguez was killed, he saw the sights of Santa Monica. Early one morning, Jack left his room at the Cecil Hotel and strolled the five-minute walk to the LAPD Central Community Police Station. Flashing his ID, he explained what he was doing in the city. When he was offered the chance to go on a ride along with a local patrol officer, Jack leapt at the opportunity. The patrol officer found the small Austrian man quirky but friendly enough. He was extremely interested in Los Angeles law enforcement and constantly asked questions as he snapped photos out of the car window. A few days later, Jack returned to the police station and flirted with the female patrol officers, taking pictures of them.
香农·埃克斯利（Shannon Exley）被杀的第二天，他去观光，并试图寻找不同的名人进行采访，包括雪儿（Cher）和莎莎·嘉宝（Zha-Zha Gabor），但没有成功。他融入了同性恋骄傲大游行，在艾琳·罗德里格斯（Irene Rodriguez）被杀几天后，他观赏了圣莫尼卡的风景。一天清早，杰克离开卡塞尔酒店的房间，步行五分钟来到了洛杉矶警察局中央社区警察分局。他闪了一下身份证，解释了自己在这个城市的所作所为。当他获得与当地巡警一同出警的机会时，杰克欣然抓住了这个机会。巡警觉得这个身材矮小的奥地利人有点古怪，但还算友好。他对洛杉矶执法部门非常感兴趣，一边把着车窗拍照，一边不断地提问。几天后，杰克回到警察局，调戏女巡警并给她们拍照。
Soon after, the third American sex worker, Peggy Booth, was murdered. Upon his return to Austria, Jack Unterweger met with Chief Edelbacher to discuss what he'd learned about sex work and crime in Los Angeles. As they chatted, Chief Edelbacher admitted to Jack that he was a person of interest in the Vienna Woods murders. Jack wasn't surprised, commenting that his background made him an obvious target while reassuring the Chief that he was in no way responsible. Nevertheless, Chief Edelbacher asked Jack to provide alibis for the nights that the murdered women had disappeared. He agreed and promised to do so within two weeks. But soon enough, Chief Edelbacher received a statement from Jack Unterweger saying he couldn't give any alibis for the nights in question as he couldn't remember what he was doing. Meanwhile, almost 200 kilometres south in the Austrian city of Graz, detectives began to suspect that two unsolved murders they were investigating were linked to the Vienna Woods crimes.
不久之后，第三名美国性工作者佩吉·布斯（Peggy Booth）遇害。回到奥地利后，杰克·翁特韦格会见了埃德尔巴赫局长，讨论了他对洛杉矶性工作和犯罪的了解。在他们聊天时，埃德尔巴赫局长向杰克承认，他是维也纳森林谋杀案的重点排查对象。杰克并不感到惊讶，评论说他的背景使他成为了显而易见的靶子，同时向局长保证他绝对没有责任。尽管如此，埃德尔巴赫局长还是要求杰克为受害女性失踪的那些夜晚提供不在场证明。他同意了，并承诺在两周内提供。但不久之后，埃德尔巴赫局长收到了一份来自杰克·翁特韦格的声明，称他无法为相关夜晚提供任何不在场证明，因为他不记得自己当时在做什么。与此同时，在向南约200公里的奥地利城市格拉茨，侦探们开始怀疑他们正在调查的两起未破谋杀案与维也纳森林案件有关。
On the night of October 26, 1990, Brunhilde Masseur was standing on her regular corner in Graz's red light district. As the nearby clock tower illuminated the time of 12.15am, a taxi driver who knew Brunhilde pulled over to ask why she was out so late. Brunhilde explained that she was hoping for one last customer before heading home. She planned to take her children on an outing in the morning and wanted a bit more spending money for them. The taxi driver bid Brunhilde farewell, then continued on his way. Brunhilde never made it home that night. Two months later in January 1991, some children playing in a wooded area on the outskirts of the city came across Brunhilde's body. She was lying in a shallow brook, naked, face down, and poorly concealed by a few tree branches. Her clothing and purse had been taken, but she was still wearing her jewellery.
1990年10月26日晚，布伦希尔德·马瑟（Brunhilde Masseur）正站在格拉茨红灯区她固定的街角。当附近钟楼的时钟显示凌晨12点15分时，一名认识布伦希尔德的出租车司机把车停在路边，询问她为什么这么晚还在外面。布伦希尔德解释说，她在回家前希望能做成最后一单生意。她计划早上带孩子们去游玩，想为他们多攒点零花钱。出租车司机向布伦希尔德道别，然后继续上路了。布伦希尔德那天晚上再也没有回家。两个月后的1991年1月，一些在城市郊区树林里玩耍的孩子偶然发现了布伦希尔德的尸体。她躺在一个浅浅的小溪里，赤身裸体，面朝下，被几根树枝草草掩盖。她的衣服和钱包被拿走了，但她还戴着首饰。
She had been stabbed once in the buttock and a piece of fabric was not untightly around her neck. Due to the advanced state of decomposition, the forensic pathologist could not determine what the fabric was. Then, on March 7, 1991, 35-year-old sex worker Alfreda Schrempf also vanished from Graz without a trace. It would be another seven months before her skeletal remains were found not far from where Brunhilde had been dumped. She was face down and naked aside from a pair of red socks. Alfreda's cause of death couldn't be determined, but strangulation seemed most likely given there were no other signs of fatal injury, such as bullet, knife, or blunt force trauma. Despite their best efforts, investigators in Graz hadn't been able to find the person responsible for these crimes. But they noticed they bore striking similarities to another unsolved murder that had been committed late the previous year on the other side of the country.
她的臀部被刺了一刀，脖子上松松地系着一块布。由于尸体腐烂严重，法医病理学家无法确定那块布是什么。接着，在1991年3月7日，35岁的性工作者阿尔弗雷达·施雷姆普夫（Alfreda Schrempf）也在格拉茨离奇失踪，没有留下任何痕迹。又过了七个月，人们在离布伦希尔德被抛尸不远的地方发现了她的骸骨。她面朝下，除了穿着一双红袜子外一丝不挂。阿尔弗雷达的死因无法确定，但鉴于没有致命伤（如枪伤、刀伤或钝器创伤）的其他迹象，勒死似乎是最有可能的原因。尽管格拉茨的调查人员尽了最大努力，却一直未能找到对这些罪行负责的人。但他们注意到，这些案件与去年年底在全国另一端发生的另一起未破谋杀案有着惊人的相似之处。
31-year-old sex worker Heidi Hammerer had vanished from the Austrian city of Bregens on the night of December 5, 1990. She'd been spotted at 9.30pm standing on her regular corner near Bregens train station. A few hours later, a neighbour saw Heidi back at home in her apartment garage. She was with a short man who wore a red scarf and a beige leather jacket. That was the last confirmed sighting of her. Just over three weeks later on New Year's Eve, two hikers traversing the nearby Lüstenauer Marsch found Heidi's body. She was lying face down and almost fully clothed with her petticoat shoved down her throat. Her wrists showed restraint marks, but there was no evidence that a sexual assault had taken place.
31岁的性工作者海蒂·哈默雷尔（Heidi Hammerer）于1990年12月5日晚从奥地利城市布雷根茨失踪。晚上9点30分，有人看到她站在布雷根茨火车站附近的固定街角。几个小时后，一位邻居看到海蒂回到了她位于公寓的车库里。她和一个身材矮小、戴着红围巾、穿着米色皮夹克的人在一起。那是最后一次有人确信看到她。仅仅三周多后的除夕夜，两名穿越附近吕斯特瑙沼泽（Lüstenauer Marsch）的徒步者发现了海蒂的尸体。她面朝下躺着，几乎穿戴整齐，衬裙被塞进了喉咙里。她的手腕上有被拘禁的痕迹，但没有发生性侵犯的证据。
Her pantyhose were tied around her neck in a series of tight and intricate knots. And this time, the killer had left evidence behind. Red and black fibres on Heidi's clothing had likely come from something her assailant was wearing. When bodies started turning up throughout the Vienna woods, investigators in Graz noted how similar the crimes were to their own unsolved cases. The way the victims had been found and the method of killing was almost identical. When they found out that their colleagues in Vienna had looked into Jack Unterweger as a person of interest, they began digging into his whereabouts at the time of each murder. Hours before Alfreda Schrempf disappeared from Graz, Jack Unterweger was in the nearby town of Kufla for a reading in a local cafe.
她的连裤袜在脖子上打了一系列紧密而复杂的结。这一次，凶手留下了证据。海蒂衣服上的红黑纤维很可能是她袭击者穿着的衣物上的。当维也纳森林各处开始出现尸体时，格拉茨的调查人员注意到这些罪行与他们自己的未破案件是多么相似。受害者的发现方式和杀害手段几乎完全一致。当他们发现维也纳的同事已经将杰克·翁特韦格列为重点排查对象时，他们开始深入挖掘他在每起谋杀案发生时的行踪。在阿尔弗雷达·施雷姆普夫从格拉茨失踪前几小时，杰克·翁特韦格正在附近的库弗拉（Kufla）镇的一家当地咖啡馆里进行朗诵。
Members of the public who had come to hear him enjoyed watching Jack's soulful performance. As the event drew to a close at 10.30pm, Jack left Kufla and headed into Graz's red light district. The night that Heidi Hammerer vanished, a white vehicle with the Vienna number plate W. Jack 1 was spotted driving past the train station she stood near. Another sex worker said she had actually seen Jack Unterweger approach Heidi before she went missing. The next day, he recorded a performance of his play Dungeon at the Austrian Broadcasting Corporation Studios, just eight miles south of Heidi's apartment. Gradually, the Graz detectives pieced together a timeline proving that each time a sex worker went missing, Jack had been attending a book signing or was working nearby. Although he insisted that he had no contact with sex workers outside of his research, a woman came forward with a different story. She had been picked up by Jack Unterweger on October 17, 1990.
前来聆听的公众非常欣赏杰克充满深情的表演。随着活动在晚上10点30分接近尾声，杰克离开库弗拉，前往格拉茨的红灯区。在海蒂·哈默雷尔失踪的那天晚上，一辆挂着维也纳车牌W. Jack 1的白色汽车被拍到从她站立的火车站附近驶过。另一名性工作者称，她在海蒂失踪前确实看到杰克·翁特韦格走近海蒂。第二天，他在奥地利广播公司录音室录制了他的戏剧《地牢》的演出，该录音室位于海蒂公寓正南方仅八英里处。格拉茨的侦探们逐渐拼凑出一条时间线，证明每次有性工作者失踪时，杰克要么在参加新书签售会，要么就在附近工作。尽管他坚称自己除了研究之外没有与性工作者接触过，但一名女性出面讲述了一个不同的故事。她于1990年10月17日被杰克·翁特韦格接上车。
Not long after she entered his car, he drove her to some nearby woods and cuffed her, then began violently raping her. Frightened, the woman began to cry. This seemed to spur Jack on. When he was unable to ejaculate, he angrily released the woman before driving off. The incident had traumatized the sex worker, leaving her terrified ever since. When Jack learnt of this woman's statement, he changed his story. Now he admitted that he had picked up a sex worker once, but it was entirely consensual. The handcuffs were nothing more than a birthday gift from a friend that he had stashed in his car's glove box.
她上车不久后，他把她开车带到附近的树林里，给她戴上手铐，然后开始暴力强奸她。受惊的女子哭了起来。这似乎更加刺激了杰克。当他无法射精时，他愤怒地释放了这名女子，然后开车离去。这起事件对这名性工作者造成了心理创伤，让她此后一直生活在恐惧中。当杰克得知这名女性的陈述时，他改变了说辞。现在他承认自己确实接载过一次性工作者，但完全是双方自愿的。手铐不过是一个朋友送的生日礼物，他把它藏在汽车的手套箱里。
And suddenly, Jack claimed that he remembered what he had done on the night that one victim went missing. He'd been with a girlfriend in Vienna. Investigators knew this wasn't true. Jack had been seen by a large number of people at a poetry reading on the night in question. This outright lie convinced Austrian authorities that Jack Unterweger could indeed be the murderer they were looking for. He was placed under surveillance once again. As part of the investigation, authorities began looking into unsolved murders of sex workers in other European countries. They discovered that when Jack Unterweger had been in Prague for work in September of 1990,
突然之间，杰克声称他想起了自己在一个受害者失踪的那天晚上做了什么。他在维也纳和一个女朋友在一起。调查人员知道这不是真的。在事发当晚的诗歌朗诵会上，杰克被大量的人看到过。这个公然的谎言使奥地利当局确信，杰克·翁特韦格确实可能是他们要找的凶手。他再次被置于监视之下。作为调查的一部分，当局开始调查欧洲其他国家发生的性工作者未破谋杀案。他们发现，当杰克·翁特韦格于1990年9月因工作在布拉格时——
four months after his release from prison, a young woman named Blanka Bukova disappeared from the city after leaving a café. Blanka's body was discovered the next day in a nearby forest. She was naked and lying face down with a few sticks and twigs scattered across her body. Blanka had been stabbed once on one of her buttocks and then strangled to death with an unknown ligature which wasn't at the crime scene. Investigators' suspicions that Jack Unterweger was responsible only increased when the landlady of the hotel he'd been staying at reported seeing him in the same city square where Blanka was last seen. At around the same time that she vanished. Despite the increasing circumstantial evidence against Jack Unterweger, Vienna's district attorney concluded there wasn't enough to warrant an arrest.
就在他出狱四个月后——一个名叫布兰卡·布科娃（Blanka Bukova）的年轻女性在离开一家咖啡馆后从该市失踪。第二天，布兰卡尸体在附近的森林里被发现。她赤身裸体、面朝下躺着，尸体上散落着几根树枝和细枝。布兰卡的臀部被刺了一刀，然后被一件不在犯罪现场的未知勒索物勒死。当杰克住过的酒店的女房东报告说看到他在布兰卡最后一次被看到的同一个城市广场出现时，调查人员对杰克·翁特韦格是罪魁祸首的怀疑进一步加深了。大约就在她失踪的时候。尽管针对杰克·翁特韦格的间接证据不断增加，但维也纳地区检察官得出结论，认为证据还不足以发出逮捕令。
The district attorney in Graz disagreed and on February 13, 1992, he successfully petitioned the Graz criminal court to order Jack's arrest. Two days later, investigators rushed to Jack's apartment to apprehend him armed with an arrest warrant, but he wasn't at home. Detectives began rummaging through the residence. It was spotlessly clean with nothing out of place. However, a search soon uncovered three pairs of handcuffs, a can of pepper spray, a switchblade knife and a shotgun. As a convicted felon, Jack was not permitted to own any of these items. Detectives also found a beige leather jacket, similar to the one described by a witness who had seen Heidi Hammerer with a short man on the night of her murder. A red scarf seemed similar to the fibers found on Heidi's clothing.
格拉茨的地区检察官则持不同意见，并于1992年2月13日成功请求格拉茨刑事法院下令逮捕杰克。两天后，调查人员带着逮捕令冲进杰克的公寓捉拿他，但他不在家。侦探们开始在住所内搜翻。这里一尘不染，没有一样东西摆错位置。然而，搜查很快发现了三副手铐、一罐胡椒喷雾、一把弹簧刀和一支猎枪。作为一名被定罪的重罪犯，杰克是不被允许拥有这些物品中的任何一件的。侦探们还找到了一件米色皮夹克，这与目击者描述在谋杀案当晚看到海蒂·翁特韦格和一个身材矮小的人在一起时穿的夹克相似。一条红围巾似乎与在海蒂衣服上发现的纤维相似。
Discovered in Jack's library was a collection of books and manuscripts that featured the same unusual words used in prank calls to Rudolph Pram. Hades, the Atonement, Zenith and references to the figure eight. When investigators eventually learned about the prank calls, they struggled to determine the meaning behind these strange phrases. One possible explanation behind the reference to the figure eight was that this was the shape a restraint made when tying someone's hands behind their back. Another remark from the calls that puzzled detectives was the killer's claim, quote, To eleven, I have carried out the just punishment. Jack Unterweger was suspected of murdering seven women in Austria and one in Prague throughout the year following his release. Investigators wondered if there were three more murders they were unaware of.
在杰克的书房里发现了一系列书籍和手稿，里面带有在给鲁道夫·普拉姆的恶作剧电话中使用的那些不同寻常的词汇。“哈迪斯”、“救赎”、“极点”以及对数字“八”的引用。当调查人员最终了解到这些恶作剧电话时，他们费力地揣摩这些奇怪短语背后的含义。对数字“八”的引用的一个可能解释是，这是将某人的双手反绑在背后时，束缚物所形成的形状。侦探们感到困惑的电话中的另一个言论是凶手的声称，引述：“对于十一个，我已经执行了正义的惩罚。”杰克·翁特韦格被怀疑在出狱后的这一年中，在奥地利谋杀了七名女性，在布拉格谋杀了另一名女性。调查人员想知道是否还有他们不知道的三起谋杀案。
Also found tucked amongst the Jack's belongings was a menu for a seafood restaurant in Malibu, California. LAPD detective Fred Miller was surprised to receive a long distance call from somewhere as far away as Austria. On the other line was investigator Ernst Geiger, who wanted to know whether any women, most likely sex workers, had been strangled to death in Los Angeles between June and July of 1991. Detective Miller checked. There were three, Shannon Exley, Irene Rodriguez and Peggy Booth. Inspector Ernst Geiger was certain that Jack Unterweger was responsible. This explained why the Los Angeles serial killer had abruptly stopped after a two week killing spree. Ernst Geiger travelled to LA to investigate further. If Jack could be tied to those murders, that would make him responsible for the strangulation deaths of eleven women within one year of his release from prison.
在杰克的随身物品中还夹着一张加利福尼亚州马里布一家海鲜餐厅的菜单。洛杉矶警察局侦探弗雷德·米勒（Fred Miller）惊讶地接到来自远在奥地利的跨国长途电话。线的那头是调查员恩斯特·盖格（Ernst Geiger），他想知道在1991年6月至7月期间，洛杉矶是否有任何女性（极可能是性工作者）被勒死。米勒侦探核实了。有三位：香农·埃克斯利、艾琳·罗德里格斯和佩吉·布斯。检查员恩斯特·盖格确信杰克·翁特韦格是罪魁祸首。这就解释了为什么洛杉矶的连环杀手在为期两周的疯狂杀戮后会突然收手。恩斯特·盖格前往洛杉矶作进一步调查。如果杰克能与这些谋杀案联系起来，那就意味着他在出狱后的一年内，要对十一名女性的勒死死亡负责。
Meanwhile, Austrian authorities waited for Jack to return home so they could arrest him. Unfortunately for them, Jack had other plans. By this stage, Jack Unterweger had struck up a relationship with the seventeen year old named Bianca Muck, who was more than half his age. Within two weeks of meeting, they were living together, and a month later they got engaged. Jack was a controlling partner. He expected Bianca to cook and clean for him, forbade her from visiting her friends, and didn't like her leaving the apartment. Bianca had taken a job at a bar in Switzerland, which Jack had been supportive of, saying the pay was better than in Austria. On February 15, 1992, the same day that detectives went to Jack's apartment to arrest him, he surprised Bianca by joining her in Switzerland, unannounced. He claimed he was growing tired of all the publicity he received at home.
与此同时，奥地利当局等待杰克回家以便将他逮捕。对他们不幸的是，杰克另有打算。到了这个阶段，杰克·翁特韦格已经与一个名叫比安卡·穆克（Bianca Muck）的十七岁女孩建立了一段恋情，女孩的年龄还不到他的一半。在相识的两周内，他们就开始同居了，一个月后他们订婚了。杰克是一个控制欲强的伴侣。他期望比安卡为他做饭和打扫卫生，禁止她去看望朋友，也不喜欢她离开公寓。比安卡在瑞士的一家酒吧找到了一份工作，杰克对此表示支持，称那里的薪水比奥地利要好。1992年2月15日，也就是侦探们去杰克的公寓逮捕他的同一天，他出其不意地前往瑞士与比安卡会合，没有事先打招呼。他声称自己厌倦了国内所有的名声与宣传。
In reality, Jack had learnt of his impending arrest after someone leaked the news to the press. Soon, he told Bianca that he was being framed, and they had to flee. The couple drove 650km from Switzerland to Paris, where they booked a flight to Florida. Bianca had always wanted to visit Miami. Her favourite television show was Miami Vice, so it seemed the ideal location to hide out. The couple rented an apartment in South Beach, but struggled to make ends meet. On February 21, 1992, Jack called an Austrian radio station to publicly protest his innocence. He promised to return if his arrest warrant was withdrawn. Jack still had strong support in his homeland, with many members of the public convinced he was being framed because the police were too inept to catch the real killer.
实际上，杰克在得知有人向媒体泄露消息后，知道了自己即将被捕。很快，他告诉比安卡他遭到了陷害，他们必须逃跑。这对情侣驾车从瑞士行驶了650公里来到巴黎，并在那里预订了飞往佛罗里达的航班。比安卡一直想去迈阿密参观。她最喜欢的电视剧是《迈阿密风暴》，所以这似乎是隐蔽的理想地点。这对情侣在南海滩租了一间公寓，但很难维持生计。1992年2月21日，杰克打电话给一家奥地利广播电台，公开抗议自己的清白。他承诺如果撤销逮捕令就会回国。杰克在祖国仍然拥有强大的支持，许多公众坚信他是被陷害的，因为警察太无能，抓不到真正的凶手。
After failing to convince a former girlfriend to provide him with an alibi, Jack started contacting another woman he had secretly been seeing behind Bianca's back in Vienna. He begged her to help him by sending money. She didn't have the funds, so she passed along the request to her boss, who was the editor of a magazine called Success. He agreed to pay Jack $10,000 in return for an interview from wherever he was hiding. Jack excitedly agreed, and provided instructions for a wire transfer in Miami Beach. On February 27, 1992, Jack drove to Miami Beach, and Bianca hopped out of the car to collect the money from the wire transfer. As she did so, the couple and their vehicle were suddenly surrounded by US marshals. Unbeknownst to Jack and his girlfriend in Vienna, the editor of Success intensely disliked Jack. After agreeing to pay for an interview, he went straight to the Austrian authorities and told them about the plan.
在未能说服前女朋友为他提供不在场证明后，杰克开始联系他在维也纳背着比安卡秘密交往的另一名女性。他恳求她通过寄钱来帮助他。她没有资金，于是将这个请求转达给了她的老板，后者是一家名为《成功》杂志的主编。他同意付给杰克10,000美元，换取从他藏身之处进行的采访。杰克兴奋地同意了，并提供了在迈阿密海滩进行电汇的说明。1992年2月27日，杰克开车前往迈阿密海滩，比安卡跳下车去电汇处取钱。正当她这样做时，这对情侣和他们的车辆突然被美国法警包围。杰克和他在维也纳的女友并不知道，《成功》杂志的主编极其厌恶杰克。在同意支付采访费用后，他直接找到了奥地利当局，并把这个计划告诉了他们。
Austrian officials contacted Interpol, who in turn contacted the US marshals. They organized a stakeout, waiting in an apartment building across the street for Jack to arrive. When they saw him, they leapt into action. Upon realizing the marshals were there for him, Jack fled on foot, running through outdoor restaurants and weaving through back alleys. But soon, the marshals had incarnated, and Jack finally surrendered. He was taken to the Miami Metropolitan Correctional Center, sobbing the entire way. Detective Fred Miller and an associate flew to Miami from Los Angeles to interview him about the three murdered women in their jurisdiction. Shannon Exley, Irene Rodriguez, and Peggy Booth. Whilst there, they took his blood, saliva, and hair samples for DNA analysis. Testing revealed that Jack Unterweger's DNA matched one of the semen samples taken from Shannon Exley.
奥地利官员联系了国际刑警组织，后者又联系了美国法警。他们组织了一场埋伏，在街对面的公寓楼里等待杰克的到来。当他们看到他时，便立即行动起来。意识到法警是来抓他的，杰克步行逃跑，穿过露天餐厅，在后巷中穿梭。但很快，法警们就追上了他，杰克终于投降了。他被带到迈阿密大都会惩教中心，一路上都在哭泣。侦探弗雷德·米勒和一位同伴从洛杉矶飞往迈阿密，就他们管辖范围内的三名被谋杀女性（香农·埃克斯利、艾琳·罗德里格斯和佩吉·布斯）对杰克进行讯问。在此期间，他们提取了他的血液、唾液和头发样本进行DNA分析。测试显示，杰克·翁特韦格的DNA与取自香农·埃克斯利的其中一份精液样本相符。
With the evidence mounting against him, Jack grew fearful that he would be extradited to California, which had the death penalty. In a lucky break for him, it was against Austrian law to extradite citizens to jurisdictions with capital punishment. The deal was struck between the USA and Austria that Jack would be tried for the American murders in his home country. He was extradited to Graz and arrived on May 28, 1992, greeting the reporters who were waiting at the airport with a wide smile. While Jack Unterweger was held in a small jail at the Graz Criminal Courthouse, Inspector Ernst Geiger and criminal psychologist Fred Muller travelled to FBI headquarters in Quantico, Virginia. They enlisted the help of Special Agent Greg McCrary to create a signature crime analysis of their killer. It was clear to Agent McCrary that all the murders shared the same pattern. The killer drove his victims far out of town, strangled them with their own clothing, left their jewellery on their bodies, took their identification, dumped them near trees or water, and partly covered them with dirt and leaves.
随着对他的证据不断增加，杰克开始害怕自己会被引渡到有死刑的加利福尼亚州。对他来说幸运的是，根据奥地利法律，将公民引渡到有死刑的司法管辖区是违法的。美国和奥地利达成了一项协议：杰克将在他的祖国接受对美国谋杀案的审判。他被引渡到格拉茨，于1992年5月28日抵达，带着灿烂的笑容向在机场等待的记者打招呼。当杰克·翁特韦格被关押在格拉茨刑事法院的小监狱时，调查员恩斯特·盖格和犯罪心理学家弗雷德·米勒前往弗吉尼亚州匡提库的联邦调查局总部。他们寻求特别特工格雷格·麦克里（Greg McCrary）的帮助，以对他们的凶手进行特征犯罪分析。麦克里特工很清楚，所有的谋杀案都有相同的模式。凶手把受害者带到城外很远的地方，用她们自己的衣服勒死她们，把首饰留在尸体上，拿走她们的身份证件，把她们抛弃在树木或水域附近，并用泥土和树叶部分掩盖。
The lack of semen samples at most crime scenes indicated the killer was impotent and struck out against the women in rage. The killer was consistent with the statement from a sex worker who said Jack had attacked her after failing to climax. The reason why the murderer chose to use pantyhose in Europe compared with bras in the USA was easily explained. In Europe, sex workers did not commonly wear bras. Instead, they donned leotards and pantyhose as undergarments. The murderer was different to other serial killers, though. Instead of attacking in one familiar area, he wasn't afraid to kill in different countries. This suggested that he was intelligent, sophisticated, and organised. After two weeks of analysing the data, McCrary was convinced that one killer was responsible for all the murders, and that killer was Jack Unterweger. Jack Unterweger had owned six different cars during the year he spent out of prison, and although a search of his most recent vehicle revealed no evidence tying him to any murders, Austrian officials successfully tracked down the first car he'd bought, a BMW.
大多数犯罪现场缺乏精液样本，表明凶手性无能，并在愤怒中对女性大打出手。这与一名性工作者的陈述相吻合，该性工作者称杰克在未能达到高潮后袭击了她。凶手在欧洲选择使用连裤袜而与在美国选择胸罩相比，这一点很容易解释。在欧洲，性工作者通常不穿胸罩。相反，她们穿紧身衣和连裤袜作为内衣。不过，这个谋杀犯与其他连环杀手不同。他不是在一个熟悉的地区作案，而是毫不畏惧地在不同的国家杀人。这表明他聪明、成熟且有组织。经过两周的数据分析，麦克里确信这起连环谋杀案的罪魁祸首只有一人，那就是杰克·翁特韦格。杰克·翁特韦格在他出狱的那一年里拥有过六辆不同的汽车，尽管对他的最新车辆的搜查没有发现任何将他与任何谋杀案联系起来的证据，但奥地利官员成功追踪到了他买的第一辆车——一辆宝马。
It had long since been sold and was sitting in a junkyard, untouched. Investigators searched the vehicle and found hairs in the passenger seat. A few belonged to Jack Unterweger. Three longer hairs were also found. Only one still had its root attached. A mitochondrial DNA sample was obtained. It matched murdered Czechoslovakian sex worker Blanka Bukova with 99.99% accuracy. Additionally, the results of 142 red fibres and 153 black fibres found on the body and clothing of Heidi Hammerer were bound to be consistent with the Jack's red scarf and a pair of black woolen trousers taken from his wardrobe. Jack Unterweger was charged with 11 counts of murder in three countries. His trial began in Graz on April 20, 1994. It was the first time in Austrian history that a person had stood trial for so many counts of murder, and the media dubbed it the Trial of the Century.
这辆车早就被卖掉了，静静地停在废车场里，无人动过。调查人员搜查了这辆车，并在副驾驶座上发现了头发。其中几根属于杰克·翁特韦格。还发现了三根较长的头发。只有一根仍然连着毛根。提取到了线粒体DNA样本。它与被谋杀的捷克斯洛伐克性工作者布兰卡·布科娃的匹配度高达99.99%。此外，在海蒂·哈默雷尔的尸体和衣服上发现的142根红纤维和153根黑纤维经查明，与杰克衣柜里拿出的红围巾和一条黑色羊毛裤相吻合。杰克·翁特韦格被指控在三个国家犯有11项谋杀罪。他的审判于1994年4月20日在格拉茨开始。这是奥地利历史上第一次有人因如此多的谋杀罪名受审，媒体称之为“世纪审判”。
Members of the public began queuing up at 4.30am to get one of the 32 seats in the public gallery and catch a glimpse of Jack Unterweger as he walked into court. The defendants smiled at reporters as though he was attending a red carpet event. One hour into proceedings, a bomb threat was called in, forcing everyone to evacuate. After the threat was dismissed as a hoax, the trial finally got underway. Jack's defence blamed the media for painting him as a monster and not abiding by the principle of innocent until proven guilty. They pointed to a claim Jack made that he'd slept with more than 150 women since being released from prison, arguing that he didn't need to murder sex workers when there were so many women available to him. Jack's girlfriend Bianca gave evidence. It was obvious that she no longer wanted to be associated with him in any way.
公众从凌晨4点30分开始排队，以争取获得公众旁听席上的32个座位之一，并在杰克·翁特韦格走进法庭时一睹他的风采。被告向记者微笑着，仿佛他正在参加红毯活动。审判开始一个小时后，有人打来炸弹威胁电话，迫使所有人疏散。在威胁被排除为恶作剧后，审判终于开始进行。杰克的辩护律师指责媒体将他描绘成一个怪物，没有遵守“未经定罪即无罪”的原则。他们指出杰克声称自出狱以来已经与150多名女性发生过性关系的说法，并辩称既然有那么多女性可供选择，他根本不需要去谋杀性工作者。杰克的女友比安卡出庭作证。很明显，她再也不想与他有任何形式的关联。
She told the court how he had kept women's clothes in his basement and she found pantyhose in his glove box, evidence she'd previously kept from police. Ex-girlfriends and sex workers described brutal sex acts Jack subjected them to against their will and while they were handcuffed. An actor who was touring in one of Jack's plays gave evidence about the time Jack had told a performer, your nipples should be cut off and preserved in vinegar. Jack's defence lawyer minimised the comment, telling the jury it was just guy talk. This angered the judge, who retorted, don't count me among the guys who talk that way. A psychiatrist told the courtroom that Jack was a malignant narcissist, adding, Jack Unterweger is legally sane but mentally abnormal. He is suffering from a deep-reaching narcissistic personality disorder with sadistic tendencies.
她向法庭讲述了他是如何在地下室存放女性衣物，以及她如何在手套箱里发现连裤袜的，这些证据她以前对警方隐瞒了。前女友和性工作者描述了杰克违背她们意愿并在她们戴上手铐时对她们实施的残酷性行为。一名在杰克的一部戏剧中巡演的演员出庭作证，讲述了杰克曾对一名演员说过的话：“你的乳头应该被割下来用醋保存。”杰克的辩护律师淡化了这句话，告诉陪审团这只是男人们的聊天。这激怒了法官，法官反驳道：“不要把我算在那种说这种话的男人里。”一名精神科医生在法庭上表示，杰克是一个恶性自恋狂，并补充道：“杰克·翁特韦格在法律上精神正常，但在心理上异常。他患有伴有虐待倾向的深层自恋型人格障碍。”
When Judge Haas asked if Jack had anything to say in response to these findings, he replied, What should I say? He's the expert. The trial finally wrapped up on June 28, 1994, just before midnight the night prior. A thunderous roar was heard throughout the streets of Gratz as a section of the courtroom exploded. Shattered glass from the windows rained down onto the street and a burst water pipe caused flooding inside. A bomb had been planted in the building. Although rumours spread that the bomb was set off by Unterweger's supporters, this was never confirmed and the culprits were never identified. Fortunately, the main courtroom was spared and proceedings continued as usual the next morning.
当哈斯法官询问杰克对这些调查结果有什么要说的时，他回答道：“我能说什么？他是专家。”审判于1994年6月28日终于落下帷幕，就在前一天午夜前夕。随着法庭的一部分发生爆炸，格拉茨的街道上响起了震耳欲聋的轰鸣声。窗户碎裂的玻璃雨点般落在街上，破裂的水管导致内部发洪水。大楼里被安置了一枚炸弹。尽管有传言称炸弹是由翁特韦格的支持者引爆的，但这从未得到证实，肇事者也从未被确认。幸运的是，主要法庭完好无损，第二天上午庭审照常进行。
As per Austrian law, Jack Unterweger was the final person to address the jury before they began deliberating. He stated, I was a rat. I consumed women rather than loved them. I was a greedy, ravenous individual, hungry for life and determined to rise in life from the bottom. It wasn't me. I'm innocent. For Jack to be found guilty, five of the eight jurors had devoted in favour of his guilt. By 8.50 that night, they'd reached a verdict. As they reconvened in the courtroom, a furious thunderstorm raged outside.
根据奥地利法律，杰克·翁特韦格是陪审团开始审议前最后一位向法庭陈述的人。他申明道：“我是一只老鼠。我消耗女性而不是爱她们。我是一个贪婪、狼吞虎咽的人，对生活充满渴望，决心从社会底层奋斗崛起。不是我。我是清白的。”杰克要被判定有罪，八名陪审团成员中必须有五人投票赞成他有罪。当天晚上8点50分，他们达成了裁决。当他们重新聚集在法庭时，外面正肆虐着一场愤怒的雷暴。
Jack was found guilty of nine murders, six votes to two. He was acquitted of killing Alfreda Schramf and Regina Prem as their causes of death could not be definitively established due to the deterioration of their remains. Jack cried upon hearing the verdict. He promised to appeal before being let out of the courtroom. At 3am the following morning, a warden completing a routine check noted Jack Unterweger was lying quietly on his mattress. 40 minutes later, the same warden found Jack's lifeless body hanging from a curtain rod. He had taken his own life. His ex-fiance Bianca awoke to the news on her clock radio.
杰克以六票对两票被判定犯有九起谋杀罪。他被判无罪释放，罪名是杀害阿尔弗雷达·施雷姆普夫和雷吉娜·普雷姆，因为由于尸体严重腐化，她们的死因无法明确确定。听到裁决时，杰克哭了。在被带出法庭之前，他承诺要上诉。第二天凌晨3点，一名进行例行检查的狱警注意到杰克·翁特韦格正安静地躺在床垫上。40分钟后，同一名狱警发现杰克毫无生气的身体悬挂在窗帘杆上。他自杀身亡。他的前未婚妻比安卡在床头收音机里醒来得知了这个消息。
She got out of bed and went about her day as normal. When Jack's lawyer found out about his client's death, he announced that because Jack intended to appeal his conviction, which had not been reviewed by the court, he could not legally be referred to as guilty under Austrian law. Austria's Justice Minister had little to say about Jack Unterweger's choice to end his life, other than to say that out of all the lives he took, this, quote, was his best murder. The conviction and death of Jack Unterweger caused a period of deep reflection for those who had campaigned for his release. Special Agent Greg McCrary said in an A&E documentary about the case, You educate a psychopath. What do you have? You have an educated psychopath. We've not made him better. We've probably made him more dangerous. In 2009, Academy Award-nominated actor John Malkovich produced and starred in an operatic portrayal of Jack Unterweger's life,
她起床后像往常一样过着自己的一天。当杰克的律师得知其客户的死讯时，他宣布，由于杰克打算对尚未经法院复审的定罪提出上诉，根据奥地利法律，在法律上不能称他为有罪。奥地利司法部长对杰克·翁特韦格选择结束自己生命的决定没有多说什么，只是说在他剥夺的所有生命中，这，引述：“是他最好的一次谋杀。”杰克·翁特韦格的定罪和死亡，让那些曾为他获释而奔走呼号的人陷入了一段深的反思期。特别特工格雷格·麦克里在一部关于此案的A&E纪录片中说道：“你教育了一个精神病患者。你得到了什么？你得到了一个受过教育的精神病患者。我们没有让他变得更好。我们可能让他变得更危险了。”2009年，奥斯卡奖提名演员约翰·马尔科维奇（John Malkovich）制作并主演了一部关于杰克·翁特韦格生平的歌剧式 portrayal。
which he toured in theatres around Vienna, Spain, France, London and Los Angeles. Titled The Infernal Comedy, Confessions of a Serial Killer, the show had taken more than 10 years to write and produce. Its musical director had attended one of Jack Unterweger's poetry readings many years earlier. Of the period surrounding Jack Unterweger's short-lived release from prison, he told The Guardian, quote, It epitomised the thinking at the time that art is stronger than crime and the far too liberal idea that everybody can be changed. John Malkovich recalled first seeing Jack Unterweger on a television talk show. He became enthralled with the murderer who fooled so many people. In an interview, Malkovich also told The Guardian, quote,
他在维也纳、西班牙、法国、伦敦和洛杉矶的剧院巡演了这部剧。该剧名为《地狱喜剧：连环杀手的自白》，历时10多年才完成编剧和制作。其音乐总监多年前曾参加过杰克·翁特韦格的一个诗歌朗诵会。谈到杰克·翁特韦格短暂出狱前后的那段时期，他告诉《卫报》说：这体现了当时的一种思想，即艺术比犯罪更强大，以及那种认为每个人都可以被改造的、过于自由主义的想法。约翰·马尔科维奇回忆说，他第一次看到杰克·翁特韦格是在一个电视脱口秀节目上。他被这个愚弄了那么多人的杀手迷住了。在接受采访时，马尔科维奇还告诉《卫报》：
At the time, I didn't get it. I wondered why people believed in someone who was so obviously fake, so obviously lying. Only years later did the real story come out. . There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
当时，我不明白。我很纳闷，为什么人们会相信一个如此明显是假冒的、如此明显在说谎的人。直到多年后，真实的故事才浮出水面。.. 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。